je m'appelle arturo bris et je suis en
j'aime beaucoup le tennis et je suis un
très grand sportif la qualité qui me
décrit le mieux et social je suis un
garçon ouvert au monde qui m'entoure mon
sujet leçon de vie inspiré d'un de mes
voyages en asie
c'est fort de cela arrêtez de parler
sans cesse de vos problèmes et comment
c'est plutôt à chercher des solutions
pourquoi je vous parle de cela c'est
parce que j'ai remarqué c'est fait dans
mon voyage de huit mois en asie du sud
est plus précisément en thaïlande au
vietnam et dans six autres pays
premièrement je vais vous raconter une
petite anecdote comme veut voir je me
suis fait beaucoup d'amis là bas
ce taux vietnam en face de mon hôtel
j'avais beaucoup d'amis mais j'en ai
rencontré un en particulier
tu as le garçon dans le milieu avec un
son dans la bouche et un chandail rayé
bleu lui à chaque matin à chaque soin
sont parvenus le porter à manger pour
déjeuner il mangé du boeuf avec du riz
et pour super du beurre avec du riz et
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai commencé à
me poser les questions et j'ai remarqué
que là bas et nous en g seulement que du
riz et le riz la viande et de l'assaut
alors arrêtez de vous plaindre vous
manger deux fois de petits chinois dans
la même semaine
car leur menu et beaucoup moins
diversifiés que le nôtre deuxièmement
travail
j'ai remarqué que la boyle s'est levée
très tôt pour aller travailler mais pour
aller faire de l'exercice car là bas
l'après midi il fait très chaud alors
les conditions sont pas bonnes pour
faire des exercices l'avez peut-être aux
alentours de 5 heures 5 heures et demie
pour aller faire leurs exercices
après il se diriger immédiatement au
travail
ils font des travaux très dur comme eux
ils sont après taper sur des pierres
pour fabriquer les faits dans sa demande
de le faire toute la journée pour forcer
beaucoup et on est souvent les problèmes
de dos quand on fait ce métier est aussi
parlé du caoutchouc dans les arbres qui
demandent de rester toute la sorte toute
la journée au soleil et beaucoup de
minutie
alors arrêtez de vous plaindre
m'adresse surtout aux adultes mais aussi
pour eauze en face caen qui commencent
l'école
si ça vous tente pas arrêté de dire ça
parce que vous avez des chefs
confortable et de l'art climatisée en
quantité troisièmement et dernièrement
les maisons si vous trouvez vous vous
lis au trop dur ou encore que maison est
trop petite à dire ça car vous êtes déjà
chanceux d'avoir une maison car là bas
certaines personnes vivent dans des
maisons malpropre et insalubres il ya
même des personnes qui vivent dans la
rue comme cette dame qui est assez
écoutés plein de déchets j'ai même
remarqué que les enfants se promener
dans les déchets soit pour ramasser de
la nourriture pour leur part un ou
encore simplement pour s'amuser en
terminant j'ai répété sans cesse arrêtez
de vous plaindre mais j'aimerais vous
laisser sur une image qui montre à quel
point malgré leurs conditions de vie
plus c'est qu'elle est non les gens sont
résolus leur bonheur ils vont à chercher
dans les petites choses du quotidien et
je crois ma famille a grandement
contribué au bonheur de cet enfant car
on est allé lui rendre visite et mon
père lui a même fait une sculpture sur
ballon d'un petit chien n'avait jamais
vu ça des ballots bref des gens sont
très heureux
merci et bonne écoute